now this is weird right think back to
the unit circle because that was where
we also said that we dealt with our it's
we also dealt with parameters in this
context when you have the unit circle we
said okay any point can be stated as cos
theta sorry Avery any point on the
circumference I should say can be stated
as cos theta sine theta and so we said
look this theta what they're talking
about starts with a positive x-axis and
it goes up to the radius that connects
to your point on the circumference okay
so that's that's the theta that's cos
theta sine theta now why don't we choose
theta as the because you can you don't
have to choose thinner you can choose
other things why did we choose theta as
the parameter and the answer is in this
case if I give you theta like say a
hundred and ninety degrees hundred
ninety agrees some way like that oh no
that's too far if I give you one hundred
ninety degrees then you know
conclusively where you are on the unit
circle in other words it's unique right
190 degrees can't be anywhere else on
the unit circle it gives you this spot
and only this spot okay now if I said to
you on the other hand okay let's use the
gradient of the spot on the circle let's
use the gradient as the parameter for
the circle you quickly run into a
problem for instance suppose I said hey
the spot that I'm interested in the spot
on the unit circle that I'm I want to be
at is gradient one it has a great end of
one okay well you run into a problem
because like where is that point I can
find at least one here's one see that
guy there if I drew the tangent you can
see that would be parallel to y equals x
it would have a gradient of one but that
is not the only spot you see where the
other spot would be right it's going to
be on the directly opposite side like
like this if I move my circles not very
good but you get the idea
use your imagination you can see here
that this is is
the both tangents are gonna be parallel
both of them have a gradient of one so
the gradient doesn't work to be the
parameter for the unit circle that's on
which is the angle cuts unique whereas
the gradient is not but here what this
is saying is the gradient that's what
this this thing over here is is the
parameter for a parabola that's
confusing the gradient is the parameter
on a parabola so the reason why this
works and maybe if you started like
thinking about what a parabola looks
like draw one with me if you think about
what a parabola looks like you can see
why this actually makes sense if I go
back to my gradient equals one thing if
this is x squared equals 4a Y where
would there be a gradient of one well I
don't know just trying to use a simple
scale here something like that right
there you go there's a spot which has a
gradient of one so T would be one in
that case what happens when you look to
the right of this point what happens to
the gradient and the answer is because
it's getting steeper and steeper the
Grady is getting bigger and bigger
forever it never returns to one yeah
likewise when you come to the left go
the opposite direction the greater gets
smaller and smaller and then it just
goes it goes negative right the gradient
is unique when you find a spot on the
parabola there's only one spot that
shares the same gradient unlike say with
a circle okay so this is special about
parabolas if for example you think about
a cubic curve just go up one power you
will find that the gradient is also
doesn't make sense because here's a
cubic right if I say gradient 100 time
okay you're like look I can find a spot
over here and I can also find a spot
over here right and no matter what cubic
you've got you'll find repeat spots
where you they've got identical
gradients that should make sense if you
think about it because for instance like
this is a this could be y equals x cubed
when you differentiate this to find the
gradient the derivative
what kind of function is the derivative
the derivative is going to be a
quadratic so when you're solving for
when this derivative is equal to a
certain thing like say when it is equal
to one then of course you're going to
find two solutions excuse me because you
always get hey you always get two
solutions out of this kind of quadratic
right I mean presuming there is a
solution at all whereas the derivative
of a parabola is a linear function right
the derivative here if y equals x
squared on for a and this is another way
we can see it if you go dy on DX right
do you want DX you can see that you're
going to get 2x on 4a which is x on to a
right x on 2a
but look X on 2a X onto a you divide
both sides by 2a you just get T right so
that's just another way of seeing it
without the chain rule so because you're
getting this linear function a linear
function I you put 1 value it you get
one value out and it never repeats
itself
unlike the parabola does okay so this is
what the parameter means the parameter
any given point like what is T it's the
derivative at that point at that
location on the parabola this isn't
going to become really important later
on we try and understand well I want a
like when you're visualizing oh okay
there's a spot on this parabola and it's
parameter is negative 2 well where is
that and the answer is you don't have to
you don't have to put these values in
first to get intuition for it is you
just say well we're over here is the
gradient thing of two what's going to be
somewhere on this side right because
it's negative and it's gonna be a steep
one so somewhere further up the curve
okay so that's why we choose this as the
parameter for the parabola